for almost two years new zealand has
been largely shut off from the rest of
the world tight border restrictions have
seen it control the spread of covet 19
better than most countries with only 53
deaths from the virus
and now with the omicron variant already
circulating here the government feels
the time is right to open up there was
life before
and now life with covert
but that also means there will be life
after covert ii
a life where we have adapted
where we have some normality back
from the end of february fully
vaccinated new zealanders will be able
to return from australia without having
to quarantine
soon after it'll be extended to new
zealanders and other countries and to
all visitors by october
key to this decision was the vaccination
rate which is recovered from a very slow
start more than 93 percent of the
eligible population is now fully
vaccinated and the minimum time between
the second and third doses has been
shortened to three months
the government was also coming under
increasing pressure politically
economically and legally to open the
border
thousands of new zealanders are stuck
overseas unable to return home because
there aren't enough quarantine or miq
hotel rooms and some are taking the
government to court
it's easy to hear the word miq
and immediately associate it with
headache
there is no question that for new
zealand it has been one of the hardest
parts of the pandemic
but the reason that it is right up there
is one of the toughest things we have
experienced
is in part
because large-scale loss of life is not
at this stage quarantine will be
replaced by home isolation for 10 days
which is expected to be shortened to
seven possibly fewer in the months ahead
wayne hey al jazeera tauranga new
zealand